the movie review nobody is asking me to
review I was asking for this if I were a
smart YouTube movie taki person I do
another video on infinity war I'm not
smart I never said I was smart in fact
I'm quite booyah God we're gonna review
this come on
[Music]
life of the party so life of the party
you wouldn't know it from its title is
the movie where melissa mccarthy's
husband leaves her and she's mom whose
daughter is in college and she's like
you know what i'm gonna go back to
college finish up my degree you know how
those movies go someone who's older than
the conventional college student going
back to college
always lends for some laughs really some
heartfelt moments I think this movie had
going for it is Melissa McCarthy the mom
character ghost is the same colors that
her daughter actually goes to so you
know how it's gonna go down right it's
gonna be pretty cliche daughter's gonna
be really embarrassed wants to hide the
fact that her mom's at this college
gonna be awkward for everybody but by
the end she'll learn to actually roll
with it and learn that her mom is
actually kind of cool I would be cliche
it's not really how the movie goes now
the daughter is actually pretty cool
with it very early on in fact Melissa
McCarthy's characters friends circle is
her daughter and her daughter's for him
so it's not really cliche it's much
simpler than cliche so there's no real
friction there's nothing from Melissa
McCarthy's character to really overcome
as ever she hooks up with a dude and now
he's kind of a clinger so she needs to
shake him a little bit not really a big
deal she needs to give her midterm
presentation and she doesn't like
presenting things I guess that's the
main thing she needs to overcome by the
end of the movie oh there's a bully
there's a couple bullies in the movie a
couple girls give her [ __ ] for being a
mom in college they only give her [ __ ] a
couple times and she's really she's too
old to give a [ __ ]
oh there's 20 year olds talking [ __ ] oh
no nothing's really binding her down in
the movie like if you look at Van Wilder
near the beginning of the movie the
thing that sets the entire movie up is
Van Wilder gets cut off financially
his father's like no more money for
college dude you make it on your own
that's the point if Van Wilder he gets
stonewalled
that kind of situation happens at a
point in this movie but well into the
final act so it's really just kind of
this inconvenience to need to overcome
like all right I guess we'd better do
something about that do what this movie
is going forward is it actually was a
sweet movie I like the premise I like
the message I like the fact that this
lady's like I'm gonna make my life
better and I'm gonna finish college some
people might think I'm too old to do
that but I like the fact that this lady
who is seemingly too old to do that did
that I think more people should do that
I feel like that's a thing that people
run into it I want to go back to college
I want to make their lives better but
they're like I I feel like I'm too old
to do that and you're never too old to
go back into a [ __ ] ton of debt if it
means changing your life for the better
in the
life of the party was more enjoyable and
I thought it would be I thought it was
it was just sweeter than I thought it
would be the movie has sentimentality
going for it but in the end there wasn't
a lot from Melissa McCarthy's character
to overcome there wasn't a lot of
friction there wasn't a lot going
against her I'm not gonna remember this
movie cuz it never really had to root
for the main character I mean you're
rooting for her in the sense that she's
the main character but she was never
really an underdog other than her
husband leaving her at the beginning
everything else was kind of works out
for just cool I guess but it doesn't
give you a reason to be there the movie
has some laughs it has some chuckles
let's say the movie probably be a better
time if you were drunk ya know it's
Barney all right so Avengers infinity
war how many times have you seen it are
you gonna say it again there's one good
let's just be real about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]